[Music]
check this out
on a London traffic cam a seagull got
right up into the camera stole the show
this thing's everywhere look at that in
that hilarious just stood there and you
get half the world watching it was
pretty funny anyway I just want to share
it with you anyway moving on not sure if
you saw this story but a probably Mark
Zuckerberg built something called a
sleep box for his wife a lot of people
are asking what's a sleep box and we
looked into it and we found out that one
of the things that you want to decide is
okay alright see go see you go you're
hugging my shot see go you're
replicating what happened in this video
clip please get out of here go ahead see
go out out you're just doing it yeah
anyway you look very unwell yeah anyway
moving on in other news uh-huh and then
that guy and I'm like what are you
talking about and then he said and then
she said and what again all right see go
I said move see
Moo oh she goes hey well that's Eagles
gone we can move on with other matters
yes well they built a cyclotron in
Norway what well this is unheard of cuz
she calls returned yeah yeah she's back
just like in that video remember from
before now what
yeah our writers took stuff our writers
took something that happened and made it
happen here but our oh that oh there's
two happens to you two Wow did not see
that coming must have been a pretty must
have been a pretty late night for those
scribe someone in the room probably said
well what should be the twist and
someone else said I have a twist let's
get the [ __ ] out of here and see our
families
I'm hungry that was the old twister ooh
on that one anyway back to me now we
finally got rid of old seagull you won't
be seeing him again now to talk about
who's on the show mmm huh he's not here
good well we got a scrap looks so dead
it's no damage so like when you got out
of the trash yeah I'm not even sure
that's a seagull noise it's a kitten
it's a kid that's the cat that's the cat
that killed the seagull this happened in
London and now what happened here good
night everybody didn't intend it all
right we're good you can go now see go
[Music]